[Musique]
ce n'est pas ce que tu connais mais qui
tu connais et surtout
[Musique]
je m'appelle Jérémy valogenbos et
pendant les 15 prochaines minutes je
vous aider à pouvoir des relations
et accélérer votre réussite
ça c'était moi quand j'étais plus jeune
j'étais quelqu'un de très timide très
introverti
j'étais vraiment mal à l'aise avec les
autres j'étais terrorisée
pire encore à l'âge de 15 ans j'étais à
l'école en Belgique il y a des cours de
langue français néerlandais et à ce
moment là j'avais un appareil dentaire
vous voyez avec un palais et c'est très
difficile de parler et je vais prononcer
à moi en néerlandais et j'y arrivais pas
du coup le professeur m'a mis devant la
classe il m'a demandé de répéter une
fois
deux fois trois fois
dix fois 20 fois et j'ai vécu une
humiliation totale
et là je me suis dit plus jamais plus
jamais et à ce moment c'est à ce moment
là que je me suis mis en mode Warrior je
me suis dit ok mode Warri activer on
veut faire de belles études de grandes
études du coup j'ai fait polémique pour
ensuite avoir un super bon job et moi
j'ai commencé dans le consulting dans un
cabinet international une big five pour
après avoir une grande carrière et
conseiller les plus grands dirigeants et
le but en or d'entreprise du monde
et donc je suis dans le consulting je me
dis yes je suis arrivé j'ai les
meilleurs résultats
j'ai la meilleure évaluation
j'ai la plus grande performance je suis
le meilleur vraiment je suis le meilleur
et pourtant
je termine 34 sur 36 dans le classement
des consultants et là je me dis mais
qu'est-ce que je fais qu'est-ce que j'ai
fait de mal
j'ai fait des études j'étais à fond
meilleure performance meilleur
évaluation c'est un échec
et en fait ce qui se passe c'est que
dans le consulting tous les consultants
sont comparés et on est comparé dans des
réunions
et dans des réunions il y a des gens
et qu'est-ce qui s'est passé avec moi
comme j'étais plus introverti j'avais la
meilleure évaluation elle était
au-dessus de la pile
dans la Réunion Jérémy qui connaît
Jérémy personne ne me connaissait et du
coup mon dossier est passé en dessous en
dessous pour terminer en bas de la pile
avec ce classement de 34 sur 36
alors je me suis dit j'ai compris une
chose
[Musique]
c'est que je misais tout
ce sont mes compétences et rien du tout
sans mes relations
souvenez-vous ce n'est pas ce que tu
connais mais c'est aussi qui tu connais
et qui te connais
du coup je me suis lancé un défi
ce défi c'est de me créer un empire
relationnel
me créer un réseau très influent
et pouvoir rencontrer les personnes les
plus inaccessibles et les plus
influantes de la planète et surtout être
à l'aise avec cette personne avec ces
personnes du coup je me suis dit qui est
connu par des milliards de gens qui je
vais me mettre dans la tête d'accéder et
je me suis dit on va prendre quelqu'un
une star d'Hollywood quelqu'un tout le
monde connaît quelqu'un qui a été à la
tête du box-office
Brad Pitt
est-ce que j'y suis arrivé c'est ce que
je vais vous expliquer pendant les
prochaines minutes
pour y arriver première étape c'est
faire des recherches comment on peut y
arriver
et j'ai découvert qu'il y avait trois
lois cachés
la première c'est la loi du vélo
la deuxième c'est la loi de mètre carré
et la troisième c'est la loi de la
réciprocité
alors la théorie du vélo la loi du vélo
je me suis dit mais comment moi qui suis
timide comment le faire comment moi qui
suis introvertis comment moi qui suis
bloqué par toutes ces barrières de
prospection comment dépasser tout ça
faut savoir et c'est important j'ai
vraiment envie de vous partager ça c'est
la timidité c'est pas une maladie on ne
met pas timide on ne meurt pas timide
c'est juste un repli sur soi par rapport
à une expérience douloureuse qu'on a
comme ce qui s'est passé avec
l'humiliation à l'école
pour dépasser ça ben c'est comme apprend
à rouler à vélo quand vous apprenez à
vous la vélo vous tombez une première
fois ça fait très mal vous êtes dans
l'inconfort vous pouvez même saigner
vous êtes dans la douleur
et après vous allez recommencer une
deuxième fois et ça va faire un petit
peu moins mal
puis vous allez recommencer une
troisième fois une quatrième fois une
cinquième fois vous allez répéter
répéter
et à un moment vous allez sur le vélo
vous allez arriver à savoir rouler et
c'est quelque chose qui est devenu
normal
du coup je me suis dit je vais faire la
même chose avec timidité surtout avec le
rejet on va aller dans la douleur on va
aller dans l'inconfort on va aller se
convoiter pour apprivoiser ça et je l'ai
tellement fait
que le magazine Forbes m'a surnommé
l'entrepreneur au sein de le rejet
du coup je me dis ok je vois comment je
peux dépasser ma timidité mais non
comment créer un réseau
influent et surtout très rapidement et
ça c'est la loi de métal qu'est-ce que
cette loi dit c'est que le nombre de
liens possibles croient de manière
beaucoup plus rapide que le nombre de
contacts que vous avez dans votre réseau
c'est basé sur une loi vous voyez la
courbe exponentielle
c'est ça accélère c'est basé donc sur
les mathématiques n fois n -20 / 2 pour
ceux qui sont pas à l'aise avec des
mathématiques regardez quatre contacts
vous voyez si flèches ça fait signe 10
contacts ça fait 45 ans et je me dis
génial je sais comment accélérer tout ça
et puis troisième loi la loi de la
réciprocité je me suis dit mais comment
comment atteindre une accessible et
c'est basé sur un conseil de vie que
j'ai reçu d'un mentor qui m'a dit Jérémy
mon garçon fais des rencontres un
maximum de rencontres
aide les gens aiment les
apporte lors de la valeur sans jamais
attendre un retour
je me suis dit qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire tout ça le mot valeur c'est le mot
le plus important
alors comment on crée de la valeur à
partir de rien
c'est en lion des besoins et des tables
ici dans le public aujourd'hui il y a
plein de besoins il y a plein de talents
et dans le monde il y a des milliards de
besoins et des millions de talents alors
comment je l'ai fait moi personnellement
quand j'ai commencé dans mon
professionnel c'est à ce moment là aussi
j'ai commencé à sortir en discothèque en
club et là je vois un club qui cherche
des ambassadeurs et le principe c'est
que vous recevez un carton enfin des
cartons et à votre nom dessus et il
suffit de donner aux gens et vous
apporter de la valeur aux gens parce
qu'ils ont des avantages et pour le club
vous amenez plein de nouveaux clients et
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé le vélo j'ai
été me confronter j'ai donné des cartes
des centaines des milliers de cartons et
je suis devenu une meilleure ambassadeur
et du coup j'ai été repéré par le patron
qui m'a dit pour te remercier tu peux
aller dans la VIP et là secret fait des
rencontres un maximum de rencontres
je vais dans ce VIP je fais des
rencontres et tenez-vous bien
oui personne sur 10 mon snobé ou mon
rejeté parce que personne ne connaît
mais en même temps je savais et c'est
là-bas Pareto que 20% des causes amène à
80% de résultats donc j'étais prêt
à accepter parce que c'est normal le
rejet pour avoir peut-être une ou deux
rencontres qui vont changer ma vie et
c'est ce qui s'est passé dans ce VIP je
rencontre une personne qui m'écoute
c'est un patron de mannequins de
concours de mannequins
exigérémy apporte-moi de la valeur c'est
la même chose pour moi trouve les futurs
talents les futurs top models
pour les mettre dans mon concours les
fait rayonner dans le monde et c'est
comme ça que petit à petit je me suis
retrouvé à Paris je passais bosser
l'appareil j'étais jusqu'au fâché lui et
de nouveau fait des rencontres un
maximum de rencontres et pareil oui
personne sur 10 semaines mais je sais
que c'est normal je sais
à Paris je fais de nouveau une rencontre
sur 10
c'est mickaëlitro c'est un DJ tu dois
beaucoup il m'a dit Jérémy aide-moi fais
la même chose je suis le DJ officiel du
Festival de Cannes donc c'était la seule
personne au monde qui faisait la musique
au dessus de la montée des marches
il me dit mets moi dans les médias
on arrive à le mettre au journal
télévisé devant plus d'un demi million
de téléspectateurs en Belgique et là il
me dit waouh c'est fou attends je veux
te présenter à d'autres personnes je
vais te présenter à mon réseau et c'est
comme ça que j'arrive à calme
et c'est aussi comme ça que j'ai
augmenté petit à petit mon cercle
d'influence
Bruxelles Paris Cannes ça a été jusqu'à
Los Angeles jusqu'à Sydney
et puis vous allez me dire finalement
Brad Pitt
est-ce que tu l'as rencontré
et on est à Cannes
et la magie du réseau c'est qu'on peut
avoir des informations et je sais qu'il
a atteint aussi je me dis waouh je vais
peut-être réussir mon défi
je suis vraiment vous voyez des
pointillés c'est la dernière étape on
dit souvent qu'on est relié à chaque
personne dans le monde par 6 degrés de
séparation
et là je suis au dernier degré et c'est
là et c'est là le sujet du tedding c'est
osé provoquer sa chance je me dis je
vais provoquer ma chance je vais y aller
à l'audace
mes connaissances m'ont dit où il était
et je me dis on prend la voiture on y va
et je me retrouve
à mes amis
face à lui
je regarde dans les yeux je souris j'y
vais je vais lui serrer la main
et je le rencontre et je vois que c'est
mon défi
ce qui se passe c'est étrangement
j'étais à l'aise avec lui
et c'est là aussi je vais vous montrer
que tout est possible dans la vie parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui sont
timides introverti qui disent je suis
foutu tout est possible dans la vie
deuxième chose c'est quand vous êtes
face à quelqu'un d'important ne le
mettez jamais sur un piédestal il est
bon dans le cinéma je suis bon dans
d'autres choses on est chacun différent
on a chacun une expérience on peut
chacun s'apprendre quelque chose que
vous apprend des choses comme vous
pouvez chacun d'entre vous m'en
apprendre et ça permet de dédramatiser
de normaliser
mais ce qui est important le but c'est
pas de rencontrer sa star préférée c'est
que le réseau ça a été mon premier
levier de succès dans tous les activités
c'est aussi important que mes études de
Polytechnique et en créant mon réseau
j'ai appris une chose fondamentale qui
peut vous servir pour votre futur et le
reste de votre avis c'est la règle
invisible du business
seul
c'est impossible de réussir quand je
restais seul derrière mon ordinateur
dans le consulting personne me
connaissait donc c'est avec les bonnes
personnes que tous vos produits tous vos
services tous vos activités peuvent
décoller et atteindre des sommets
et c'est basé sur une formule la formule
OSP que je ne respectais pas avant et le
jour où j'ai respecté
ça a changé ma vie cette formule
avant envoyer objectif vous avez tous
des objectifs des rêves
j'arrivais pas à faire le lien avec les
gens
souvenez-vous j'étais dans cette réunion
personne ne me connaissait et donc je
sais pas j'étais l'avant dernier dans le
classement aujourd'hui
et c'est là le sujet du TEDx osez
provoquer sa chance bah c'est ce facteur
X c'est vous avez des objectifs et vous
savez trouver les bonnes personnes et
vous allez oser serrer des mains
la réussite c'est trouver des personnes
trempées
ces personnes tremplin c'est des
accélères des accélérateurs de réussite
et c'est pareil dans tous les domaines
artiste start-up Marc employé
entrepreneur sportif c'est pareil dans
tous les domaines on prend en jean
Dujardin
c'est Jean Dujardin n'avait pas
rencontré niche à la zone indus
il n'aurait jamais gagné d'Oscar il
n'aurait jamais joué dans The artistes
Cristiano Ronaldo dans le sport si
Cristiano Ronaldo n'avait pas rencontré
sœur Alex Ferguson il n'aurait jamais eu
ce mental de champion
qui lui a fait devenir un des meilleurs
joueurs de la planète
je voudrais
terminer avec trois messages importants
le premier c'est un message d'un mentor
que j'ai reçu c'est insisté ça existait
les plus grandes réussites ont toutes eu
énormément de rejets je les vécu
moi-même il faut jamais le prendre
personnellement et ne jamais abandonner
vos rêves à cause de ça parce qu'il
suffit d'une rencontre et tout peut
changer
le deuxième point c'est que la réussite
c'est un parcours d'adresse
ça veut dire vous avez rencontré
quelqu'un qui va faire
quelqu'un et c'est comme ça que petit à
petit vous allez tisser votre toile
d'araignée influente et enfin peut-être
le plus important
après le verbe aimer
c'est le verbe aider
qui est le verbe le plus puissant au
monde pourquoi parce qu'on est dans les
gens vous allez créer de la valeur vous
allez activer la loi de la petiterocité
c'est ça la noblesse du networking on
n'est pas en opportuniste et quand vous
faites ça et que vous attendez rien en
retour vous allez voir et tester le que
vous pouvez avoir des choses en
puissance 1000 c'est ainsi que vous
pouvez créer
chacun d'entre vous avec vos projets de
la valeur
massive dans le monde
et je voudrais terminer avec un point
qui est crucial c'est un point que
j'avais négliger tout au début de ma
carrière
c'est que votre talent
c'est votre moteur
mais c'est pas suffisant
il faut aussi avoir un réseau
votre réseau c'est l'accélérateur et
quand vous allez vous avez les deux vous
deveniez inatteignable et inarrêtable
alors je m'étais
lancé le challenge le défi de rencontrer
comme ça c'est personne n'est plus
inflames de la planète
ce soir
c'est à mon tour de vous lancer ce
challenge je suis certain
que vous avez tous des talents que vous
êtes tous doués
alors allez provoquer votre chance
osez serrer des mains
osez accepter le rejet
osez rencontrer ces personnes tremplin
qui peut changer votre vie et surtout
oser accélérer votre exit merci
[Applaudissements]